Star Wars Episode nine director Colin
Trevorrow reveals what he thinks of fan
theories about Ray and pinch for episode
nine Colin really loves ray I love ray
Trevorrow told et Saturday he's already
seen the force awakens five times and is
talking with JJ Abrams and Rian Johnson
about what's next have you seen the
theories that Rey is Obi Wan's
granddaughter and do you have a response
I've seen all of the theories and and
you know I have to practice how to
answer these questions what I do know is
is that we're going to make sure that
that answer is deeply and profoundly
satisfying because ray is a character
that is important in this universe and
not just in the context of the force
awakens but in the entire galaxy and she
deserves it and so we'll make sure that
that that that answer is something that
feels like it was it's something that
happened a long time ago far away we're
just telling you what happened favorite
character or favorite moment from the
movie I love ray but I loved her and I
loved what what she represents in that
universe and where we can take her it's
pretty incredible by the time we get to
Episode nine you know I look at that
movie as one movie as three movies as
six movies and his 9 movies and it's
something that needs to honor a story
that has been told over over a period of
40 years Star Wars is a belief system
it's not just a story it's not just a
movie and it's something I take very
seriously
you